they made cutting class in art form and
gave an entire teen generation a new
perspective on life love and proper Car
Care so what's the cast of Ferris bu's
day off doing now the question is what
aren't they doing though Ferris bu's day
off Remains the defining film of his
career Matthew bro's breakout role
actually arrived 3 years earlier when he
played computer hacker David in the
Cyber drama War Games a part in lady
Hawk soon followed and he then became
everyone's favorite enterprising teen
when John Hughes cast him in the title
role of 1986's Ferris bu's day
off like most pretty
[Music]
fast if you don't stop and look around
once in a while you could miss it after
Ferris was a hit broadrick kept working
steadily in film and television the
decade following that film brought
leading roles in glory the freshman and
the Cable Guy not to mention the voice
of the adult Simba in the iconic Disney
classic The Lion King other memorable
movies for broadrick include 1998's
Godzilla election and Disney's Inspector
Gadget but broadrick was also an
accomplished stage actor and used that
experience when he nabbed the starring
role in the 2001 stage adaptation of Mel
Brooks as the producers and then his
2005 film 20 years later he still
divides his work between stage and
screen and in 2023 he had a supporting
role in the adult comedy no hard
feelings as well as a lead role in the
Netflix miniseries painkiller
like his co-star Allan ru's career also
started to take off in the early 1980s
after early roles in films like class
and bad boys he landed the part of
Ferris best friend Cameron fry in Ferris
bu's day off Ruck had the task of
playing everything br's Ferris is not
and he did it so well that he steals
just about every scene in the movie with
his anxious
comedy Cameron what's going to happen to
it's in a garage it could get wrecked
stolen scratched breathe on wrong Ru
continued to act regularly through the
rest of the 1980s but the 1990s was
where he really got prolific with his
work on the big and small screens if you
only know him as Cameron you might be
surprised to realize that he was also
Gunslinger Henry French and Young Guns 2
and played Captain Harryman in Star Trek
generations he landed on television not
long after stirring alongside Michael J
fox in the network hit Spin City as
Chief of Staff steuart bondek more than
a decade later he joined the main cast
of the short-lived TV remake of The
Exorcist as Henry rant and beginning in
2018 was part of the Ensemble of HBO's
award-winning drama succession he's
never left the movies though appearing
in war machine in 2017 2023 is the
burial and the sequel to Wind River
aside from Ferris bu's day off Mia sah
is also remembered for her standout
performance as Princess Lily in the
Ridley Scott directed fantasy epic
Legend opposite Tom Cruz she followed
that up the very next year with when she
took on the part of Ferris aloof but
Charming girlfriend Sloan Peterson as
Sloan Sarah added a level of cool to the
often goofy antics of her co-stars while
still being in on the joke the entire
time of course Hollywood took notice of
this opening onew punch and Sarah spent
the next two decades working regularly
in film and television unfortunately she
struggled to find the same level of
success as she did in the mid 80s while
she did appear in some popular films
including time cop as the wife of
jeanclaude Van Dam's character her later
career never matched her mid 80s hits
that said she is notable for being the
first actor to play Harley Quinn in live
action nabbing the role in the
short-lived Birds of Prey Series in 2002
Sarah stepped away from acting in the
early 2010s and one of her final roles
was as Princess languir in the film
Dorothy and The Witches of odds and its
miniseries after leaving Hollywood Sarah
embarked on a career as a poet and
devoted time to her family though
Jennifer Gray only performed in fewer
than a dozen roles over the the course
of the80s several of them proved to be
Classics in 1984 she co-starred in Red
Dawn with Patrick sesy and had a small
role in The Cotton Club from director
Francis Ford Copa then she played jeie
the smarmy vindictive sister of Matthew
broadrick Ferris in Ferris bu's day off
while that part garnered some attention
for her it was her role as baby in
1987's Dirty Dancing that made her a
star offscreen however gray was quietly
dating her Bueller co-star and onscreen
brother bradrick and the pair were
involved in a devastating head-on car
collision just before the release of
Dirty Dancing a woman and her adult
daughter were both killed as a result of
the crash and the tragedy haunted
broadrick and gray for many years
physically and emotionally over the next
decade gray continued to work but failed
to regain her star status appearing in
lesser known films like wind and red
meat she took a break from acting after
the birth of her daughter in the early
2000s and appeared mostly on TV after
her return which included a memorable
appearance on season 11 of Dancing With
the Stars more recently gray showed up
in recurring roles on Gray's Anatomy and
the Roseanne reboot the Connors Lyman
Ward's screen acting career stretches
all the way back to the 1970s when he
began appearing in guest roles on TV
show Classics like Bonanza Battlestar
Galactica one day at a time and the very
first episode of lever and Shirley he
continued to work regularly throughout
that decade and by the 1980s he was
appearing in films like protocol Moscow
on the Hudson and a nightmare on Elm
Street to Freddy's Revenge as Ferris
bu's father in day off he brings a sense
of likable cluelessness to the comedy
after Ferris ber Ward stayed working
with credits including Murder She Wrote
Family Ties Jag Monk and many more in
the 2010s his acting work began to slow
down though he had a major role in an
episode of transparent in 2015 Hollywood
wasn't his only career though turning to
writing in the 2010s ward published his
first novel Fortune's tie Cindy pickets
breakthrough as as a Screen Actor came
in 1977 when she was cast on the long
running soap opera Guiding Light where
she appeared in 22 Episodes by the 1980s
more TV and film roles were flowing in
including appearances on some major hits
like Magnum PI she secured the role of
Ferris Beer's mother Katie who plays
opposite star Matthew broadrick in some
of the film's funniest early moments as
the teen uses her to convince the world
that he's sick oddly enough her onscreen
husband Lyman Ward later became her real
life husband though they divorced in
1992 after ber picket showed up in the
1987 TV miniseries America and the abyss
knockoff deep star 6 in the 2000s she
was as active as ever making single
episode stints in shows like Burn Notice
Saving Grace The Client List and The
Mentalist outside of Ferris Beer's day
off of course picket is best known for
her role as Dr Carol noino in the
award-winning medical drama St Elsewhere
Edie mcer became beloved to audiences of
the 80s thanks in no small part to her
role as principal Rooney's eccentric
secretary Grace in Ferris Beer's day off
he jeopardizes my ability to effectively
govern this student body well makes you
look like an ass is what he does add she
was no newcomer to Hollywood though and
in the mid 1970s she had been a regular
on the Richard prior show and Tony
Orlando and Dawn and had a brief role in
the film carry before she hit her stride
the following decade on Harper Valley
PTA and the Dukes at the movies outside
of her role as Grace and berer McClurg
was a recurring presence in chichin
Chong projects like chichin Chong's next
movie and the Corsican Brothers she also
had cameos in Mr Mom and Planes Trains
and Automobiles before her appearance as
Chastity Pariah in Elvira Mistress of
the dark the 9s saw her in a number of
fan favorite films like Flubber and
Natural Born Killers as well as a flurry
of major Network hits mcclurg's voice is
one of the things that made her
distinctive too and she's lent it to
animation many times from the Rugrats
movie to Wreck it Ralph sadly in 2019
mcclurg's Health began to decline and
her family appointed a conservator to
manage her Affairs as she was no longer
able to live unassisted in 2022 she was
tragically the victim of elder abuse and
alleged sexual assault and her family
successfully got an order of protection
against a longtime friend who was
alleged to have attempted to defraud her
there are a few examples in Ferris bu's
day off of actors who come in for just
one scene but leave a lasting impression
as they get roped into Ferris
Shenanigans and schemes Jonathan smok is
arguably the most memorable of these
actors as the Mater D at a restaurant
who refuses to believe Ferris is the
Sausage King of Chicago are you
suggesting that I'm not who I say I am
I'm suggesting that you leave before I
have to get snooty snoody snotty snotty
schach had already been working for a
few years by the time he was hired for
Ferris berer most notably on the TV
series double trouble and has continued
to make regular appearances in film and
TV his recent work includes guest spots
on the Goldbergs flaked transparent Two
Broke Girls and more but he's not just a
busy actor schmock is also an
accomplished and prolific screenwriter
particularly in the realm of TV comedies
his credits include co-developing
Sabrina the Teenage Witch co-creating
brotherly love and scripting for shows
like Blossom Dharma and Greg Real Time
with Bill Maher and Young and Hungry
Charlie Sheen has made a career as
Hollywood's bad boy that image is
perfectly a propo considering his part
in Ferris bu's day off as a punk
teenager who romances Jennifer Gray's
character I'm me are you in here for
drugs why are you here drugs he took the
role when he was on the cusp of
superstardom the son of famed actor
Martin Sheen Charlie had already
appeared alongside gray and red Dawn and
after ber the actor had a spectacular
run that included Classics like Wall
Street platoon and Major League Sheen
parlayed those 80s hits into modest 90s
success after a pair of Hot Shots parody
movies he tried his hand at becoming an
action star with the chase terminal
velocity and the sci-fi thriller the
arrival that never really panned out but
in 2000 he took over for Michael J Fox
as the lead in Spin City in 2003 Sheen
was cast as Charlie Harper in the hit
sitcom 2 and a Half Men He remained on
the show until 2011 when clashes with
Chuck Lori led to his departure a series
of very public issues in including drug
abuse and messy divorces plagued Sheen
in the 2010s but in 2019 he revealed
that he'd been sober for more than a
year and was in therapy in 2023 he and
Lori buried the hatchet and the actor
was handed a recurring role in The
Producers upcoming Max comedy how to be
a
bookie
berer
buer actor Ben Stein appears in only two
scenes but he's so perfectly embodies
the archetype of the tedious droning
High School teacher that he carved out a
niche as Hollywood's go-to guy for
playing monotone Boors most memorably he
portrayed teacher Mr kwell in The Wonder
Years an airport customer service rep in
Planes Trains and Automobiles and Rabbi
Goldberg on Family Guy not counting
numerous cameos as himself in a long
running ey drops campaign offscreen
Stein was a speech writer for presidents
Richard Nixon and Gerald Ford and has
written extensively on economics and
legal issues for the Wall Street Journal
fortune and the New York Times he
starred in two shows for Comedy Central
the talker turn Ben Stein on and the
game show Win Ben Stein's Money where
contestants who demonstrated more
knowledge than the well-educated well-
read Stein won a portion of his salary
in recent years Stein has mostly stayed
away from Hollywood and focused more on
being a spokesperson for the Republican
Party he frequently appears on Outlets
like Fox News and Newsmax in 2023 he
came under Fire for racist comments made
about anim a pancake syrup Christy
Swanson's role as Ferris classmate
Simone adamle wasn't quite a standout
but audiences still know her because
less than a decade on Swanson originated
the role of Buffy in The Buffy the
Vampire Slayer franchise she also played
the titular role in mannequin 2 on the
Move taking over for Kim catrell from
the 1987 cult classic Swanson's career
in the 1990s was hit or miss but she did
have an important role in the
well-received But ultimately doomed
series Early Edition she also appeared
in a variety of popular films including
the critically acclaimed John Singleton
drama Higher Learning and the Joe pesi
crime comedy eight heads in a duffel bag
into the 2000s it was mostly TV where
Swanson made a name for herself with a
recurring role in Psych and episodes of
CSI Miami and just shoot me though she's
mostly acted in cable TV movies in the
last decade she did appear in a trio of
episodes of Seal Team in
2019 actor Richard Edson plays the
garage attendant who sneaks off with
Cameron's car and goes for a joy ride it
was just his fourth acting role and he
barely got any lines but he appeared in
a host of major movies in the ensuing
years beginning with Howard the Duck and
platoon the same year Edson went on to
show up as private abersold in Good
morning Vietnam and as veto and do the
right thing edson's Unique Look allowed
him to stand out too and that has
perhaps been the reason that he's never
been without work even if he never did
become a big star the 9s saw him showing
up all over film and TV whether it was
the adventures of Pete and Pete or the
much maligned Super Mario Brothers movie
in which he played Spike Koopa we could
go on forever with all of the projects
that Edson has worked on but no doubt
you've seen him around as he's kept
himself busy year after year with one of
his more recent projects being the indie
film seeing red in
2022 Not only was Ferris ber one of
Louis Anderson's first acting
experiences his comedy career was also
just getting started his role in the
film had him playing a flower delivery
man and gave him no lines at all the
movie came into theaters just 2 years
before his first starring role in 1988's
the wrong guys which was based on a
story by John Hughes by the early 90s
Anderson was a huge comedy star and in
1994 he got his own animated kid show
Life with Louie which ran for three
seasons then the Louis show though
Anderson continued with standup and
could be seen regularly on television he
became best known for game shows in the
early 2000s he was hired as the host of
The Family Feud Revival and made many
appearances on the new Hollywood Squares
and Hollywood Squares he'd returned to
the Circuit in 2017 frequently appearing
as a guest star on funny you should ask
in some of his final acting roles
Anderson appeared on young Sheldon in
2020 and had roles in Surge party that
same year and no activity a year later
sadly Anderson died in 2022 from
complications caused by cancer at the
age of 68 actor Max perlick played
Ferris snot-nosed classmate who was here
when benstein called out his name during
roll call perlick may have had little to
say in the film but his career is an
interesting one starting with the fact
that he dropped out of high school to
pursue acting with his first movie role
being in the John Hughes film despite
having very little to say perlick was
able to turn his part into more movie
and TV appearances with his next
projects including Can't Buy Me Love and
an episode of 21 Jump Streets though
he's rarely had what would be considered
meaty roles perlick managed to carve a
niche for himself in the industry and
some of his betterk known films include
Mel Gibson's Maverick in 1994 in feeling
Minnesota in 1996 like many character
actors he has shown up on tons of TV
shows over the years from Nash Bridges
and Gilmore Girls to the shield in
Crossing Jordan he appears as Hank and
Twin Peaks the return as well but his
biggest TV part was on the FX series
Justified where he played the sniveling
mob boss's son Samy tonin in four
episodes of the critically acclaimed
crime drama and his constant work in the
industry hasn't been entirely thankless
perlick won an independent Spirit award
for his supporting performance in
Drugstore Cowboy in
1990 Jeffrey Jones screen acting career
took off in the mid '70s thanks to being
cast in projects like the minseries the
Adams Chronicles and by the 1980s he was
an in demand character actor after
landing roles in easy money amadas and
other projects He was cast as Ed Rooney
and Ferris Bueller's Day Off Jones
continued to pick up major roles after
his buler success starring in the
short-lived West Craven produced
off-the-wall forgotten sitcom the people
next door surrounding the failure of
that show he found Safe Harbor in Tim
Burton films like Beetlejuice Edwood and
Sleepy Hollow other major roles included
being a conduit for the dark Overlord in
Howard the Duck the Hunt for Red October
The Crucible The Devil's Advocate and
role as newspaper publisher aw Merrick
in the acclaimed HBO series Deadwood in
2003 Jones pleaded no contest to a
charge of employing a teenage boy to
pose for nude photos and in 2010 he was
sentenced to community service for
failing to update his sex offender
status
these legal issues led to fewer screen
appearances in the 2010s but in 2019 he
did reprise his role of Merck in
Deadwood the movie if you or someone you
know may be the victim of child abuse
please contact the childhelp National
child abuse hotline at 18004 a child 1
1800 422 4453 or contact their live chat
[Music]
services